SATYAJEET SALGAR: Hi,
I'm Satyajeet.
I'm here with Ibrahim and we're
here to tell you about
our session at Google I/O,
which is about using the
YouTube Live APIs to stream
content onto YouTube, either
as a content partner or as a
developer to build tools to
stream live onto YouTube.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about YouTube, the Live
platform and the APIs.
And Ibrahim is going to dive
into the details of what we're
going to talk about
at Google I/O.
Ibrahim, does that sound
like a plan?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Sure.
Sounds good.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: All right.
First, let me tell you a little
bit about YouTube.
YouTube is a great place
to watch video.
Over 1 billion users
every single
month come onto YouTube.
They watch over 4 billion
hours of content.
72 hours of video are
uploaded to YouTube
every single minute.
And YouTube, at this point,
is a truly cross-platform
experience, about 25% of
our views globally
are on mobile devices.
We're also a great place
to search for video.
In fact, YouTube is the second
largest search engine in the
world today.
We're extremely proud
of the work we've
done with Live recently.
We have an incredible stream
quality and some great
features on the Live platform.
As a developer or a content
partner, you only need to send
us one stream.
We transcode it to different
resolutions and device formats
and deliver the right stream
to the user based on their
device and the bandwidth
they have available.
We also let users get
back and forth in
the stream very easily.
We make it easy for you to add
add cues and slates into the
stream as well.
We recently released the YouTube
live APIs so that you
can either make it easier for
you as developers to stream
content on the platform or build
apps that take advantage
of the platform and help content
partners build great
experiences.
Ibrahim, do you want to say more
about what you're going
to talk about at Google I/O?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Sure.
As Satyajeet mentioned, we have
a great live streaming
platform, and a well designed
live streaming API that will
let you schedule, update, and
manage your broadcast.
Create reusable streaming points
with their settings and
inserting ads for the YouTube
content partners.
You will have a nice
introduction of the API and
its resources.
I will also go over a few
samples showing you how it's
easy to get started
and how it can be
applied to your use case.
If you would like to get an
earlier look of the API, the
[INAUDIBLE]
are at developers.googl
e.com/youtube/v3/live.
If you want to go over the
examples of the language or
your choice, you can also check
out YouTube API samples
project at code.google.com/
p/youtube-api-samples.
In those examples, news
broadcast, livestreams and
[INAUDIBLE]
of live streaming API.
You can also see them
in [INAUDIBLE]
documentation.
Last, but definitely not the
least, we will have mobile and
cloud streaming demos using
the API [INAUDIBLE].
On the other hand, we have also
partner integrations in
our sandbox area.
Wouldn't it be fun if we
showed it all now?
Right?
Come and see the next
[INAUDIBLE].
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We're really
excited to see you at Google
I/O and tell you more about
our platform, our APIs, as
well as introduce you to
partners that are taking
advantage of the platform.
Look forward to seeing you
in San Francisco in May.